the Attorney General Jeff Sessions joins
us right now
mr. in general thanks for coming up
thank you so this is I think it's fair
to say an emergency if a city government
is making it possible for an accused
killer to go free simply because they're
morally opposed to federal immigration
law that's setting up a conflict between
the state the federal government where
how can this be stopped what's the next
step here the American people have got
to speak first and foremost to these
governmental leaders it's just
unacceptable to take this case in Denver
that you just cited where the individual
will be released from jail ice officers
are not going to stop looking for him
they're going to go out to find him
there'll be a greater risk they'll place
people in the community a greater risk
to try to make an arrest there when they
could have been safely picked up in the
custody from the custody of the Denver
authorities so this situation is very
very serious and it represents a
commitment from the hard left these
activist groups to open borders and non
legal enforcement of immigration cannot
be the policy of the United States of
America so some democratic politicians
say the states are not and I think
they're legally correct are not
obligated to carry out federal law but
then others including the mayor of
Oakland have gone farther and actively
tried to subvert federal law as mayor
Libby Schaaf of Oakland did the other
day by warning people that federal
agents were coming does that constitute
obstruction of justice and should she be
prosecuted for that we're looking at
that our fabulous ice officers and Tom
Holman are keeping us posted on what's
really happening there those kind of
things depend on the law and the facts
and we'll evaluate them at the
Department of Justice but yes this is a
radical ideology it's contrary to the
American law the supreme law of the land
is American immigration law and it must
be enforced else we'll just have open
borders and that cannot be well we're
getting we have open borders in effect
in a lot of ways now we're getting
something looks like insurrection almost
the biggest state saying we're gonna
actively work to undermine basic federal
law do you worry that the country won't
hang together I don't think so I think
this is an extreme
when I was in California I heard
countless people tell me they were
embarrassed and outraged about what was
going on I think these people have just
been able to get away with it not being
challenged not being challenged
intellectually as to the meaning of what
they're doing how radical it is how
unacceptable it is how it places the
lives of American police officers and
ice officers at greater risk as well as
our community is at greater risk because
we keep criminals in the country that
are due to be deported do you see how if
you're looking on as an observer of this
it does seem like the federal government
is toothless in the face of this
challenge
elected officials stand up give the
finger to federal immigration
authorities to law enforcement with
impunity it does seem like they the
mayor of Oakland has more power than the
than the feds well Tucker why the we're
going to use every lawful - we have to
push back against this activity you can
be sure of that I will say however that
ultimately in this country the American
people have the final word and they have
got to analyze what their leaders are
doing and if they're promoting these
kind of unlawful unwise and dangerous
policies they need to be held to account
and when the political needle starts
moving I think you'll see politicians
start changing the Attorney General you
replaced the one Attorney General before
that Eric Holder has endorsed this do
you think it's odd that a former chief
law enforcement officer in the country
would be endorsing ignoring federal law
well he's being hired by the state being
paid a legal fee to represent the state
of California but I totally believe that
this policy that they are defending in
California is unwise and many places
clearly illegal and we're going to
challenge its legality and we're going
to challenge its wisdom and we're going
to defend federal law officers and state
law officers who are out there trying to
do their duty every day and of being
placed at much greater risk because oh
they won't even let the police talk to
the federal officers who are the only
ones that can actually deport
criminal alien so just to switch gears I
think a lot of people certainly I think
a lot of our viewers have lost
confidence in law enforcement and
intelligence gathering agencies in this
country because they think they've been
used for political purposes to spy on
Americans without real cause and Carter
page I think would be at the top of that
list don't you think it would go a long
way to restoring public confidence in
those agencies if the rest of us had
some sense of the basis upon which the
FISA warrants were gotten for spying on
Carter page it is our responsibility and
I think my responsibility to ensure that
the FISA process has carried out
professionally properly lawfully and
with integrity I intend to do that we
are working on that now our Office of
Inspector General has almost 500
employees investigators and prosecutors
and they're going to work on this and
get to the bottom of it but could we see
I mean because there's so much lying
about this from partisan lying maybe
from both sides I know from one about
why the court granted the government the
right to spy on this American citizen
wouldn't it just dispel all the myths
and the conspiracies if we could see
redacted of course but if we could see
the basis of Freud well we've never
produced publicly the FISA warrants but
I have to tell you Tucker we produce
more documents in this case more on
information to the Congress and to the
public then I think any attorney
general's office in history has we're
going to go as far as we can go to make
things public and we're going to ensure
you don't think we needed a special
prosecutor to look into this well we're
going to get to the bottom of it it
could be one day that a special
prosecutor bee would be required but
we're going to look at this both with
attorneys and within the inspector
general's office and they will get to
the Box you're giving a speech tomorrow
essentially about the rule of law I
think I read a copy of it to the
Federalist Society and it raised a
question in my mind about judges
shouldn't the Congress act as a as a
counterbalance against judicial
overreach if there's a judge who was
clearly not even consulting the
Constitution and making law why wouldn't
the Congress try to balance that out you
know it's gotten to the point where
Congress I think has been
- willing to cede its powers I felt that
when I was a member of the Congress I
feel it even more so now as the Attorney
General
what I'm finding single judge is one out
of 600 issue an executive order an
injunction a court injunction against
executive orders of the executive branch
of the United States without a
foundation for that you could have 10
other judges who opposed it but the one
who enjoins it their opinion is upheld
it may take 18 months to get them a
clear the Supreme Court it is disrupting
the ability of this government to
function and I'm really concerned about
it it's time but the the nation to
reconsider these injunctions yeah that's
not democracy that's monarchy or
something
mr. gentle thank you very much for you
appreciate it